sub-classing was really easy when we
were using the functional pattern here
but let's explore how we might do this
if we were using the pseudo-classical
pattern for our base class how do we go
about writing pseudo classical
subclasses for practice let's start this
program from scratch it'll be good to
build up the program one line at a time
anyway since the pseudo-classical code
we're about to write is gonna look so
different from the functional code we
already wrote furthermore let's use some
different sample code in our run j/s
file it'll be easier to think about this
if we're only instantiating one instance
of the superclass and one instance of
one of the subclasses so just like
before van is a subclass of car ami is
an instance of van and this new Zed
object will be an instance of a car we
won't examine the cop class here or any
instantiation of it because we only need
to see one example of a subclass to make
the point by reading this first line of
code I can tell that I'm going to need a
car function to make instances of cars
and it'll take an input to use as a
location for the new car inside the car
function we will do the work that is
specific to one instance of a car in
this case adding a property that should
be different across all cars but what
about that move property that car
instances like Zed appear to need take a
moment to decide where you think you
would add that functionality for this
pseudo classical car class edit the car
class so that it exhibits the move
function that we remember from before